[Applause]
it's time to talk parenting trends and
understanding kids as i
momsplained it all let's start with some
new music ed sheeran just released the
first single off of his
as yet untitled fifth studio album on
friday and it's called bad habits take a
listen
[Music]
[Music]
conversations
the video for the song shows him with a
pink suit accented by vampire fangs
grit glittery bruised eye shadow and
blonde hair he'll be appearing on the
late late show with james corden
all this week and this just in
[Music]
over the weekend he revealed that he has
written a song for the new
bts record he's worked with them before
and says they are
super cool guys bts's new record comes
out on army day
july 9th and how is this even
possible news a new study found that
ladies you might want to start eating
chocolate for breakfast a new study
looked at the specific
effects in older women they had to eat
100 grams of milk chocolate within an
hour of waking up
now 100 grams equates to more than two
full-sized hershey bars the women in the
study did it for two weeks and did not
gain any weight
and they didn't change their diet in any
other way they did
end up eating slightly less throughout
the day so it may make you feel
full longer researchers believe it also
may up your metabolism
and help you burn more fat and finally
let's talk
tick-tock trends this mom needs to lock
down her ipad
tick-tock user stay fit stay lit
recently posted a video claiming
her 10-month-old son managed to spend
over 10
thousand dollars on her ipad and she had
no idea she was busy cooking dinner
while her baby boy entertained himself
with the tablet
but ended up purchasing pricey upgrades
to her tesla
when your 10 month old purchases the
full self-driving package through the
tesla app
and you didn't know it until you checked
bank statements
and you find out this is non-refundable
48 hours after
why isn't there a password or security
measure before you could make
tick tockers were quick to question how
this could ever happen she said in a
follow-up video that when you buy a
tesla car
you have an account with them and it's
linked to your bank account
and that way when you take your car in
for service or repairs they have all
your bank info on file already
so her baby boy was able to access that
app on her ipad and buy the upgrade
without her knowing
or the bank questioning the transaction
we all knew having babies
was expensive i just don't think we knew
it was that expensive
i'm mercedes and now you've been
momsplained